for those of you for some reason are not
obsessed with the Fermi paradox Enrico
Fermi posed the following same guy with
the nuclear reactor in Chicago and all
that posed the following question if
there are alien worlds as you might
claim since there are billions of stars
in billions of galaxies you would expect
billions of planets and then you'd
expect a few millions earth-like of
earth-like planets where why haven't we
heard from these other civilizations and
the answer I think is not that
complicated
we've only been listening for other
civilizations for 50 years 70 years
depend it depends how you count and you
have to acknowledge that civilizations
have to emerge and be able to
communicate at the same time when you
have something that's been going on for
thirteen point six billion years there's
a lot of opportunities to miss each
other so the Fermi paradox for me is not
a reason to give up and take the black
capsule and have no hope for humankind
because we are just this unique thing in
the middle of nowhere and we'll never
amount to anything no for me the Fermi
paradox drives us forward why haven't we
heard for anybody because we're not
listening hard enough we're not being
diligent enough we're not thinking it
through well enough so we at the
Planetary Society support the of course
support their search for
extraterrestrial intelligence but the
extra search for extraterrestrial
intelligence in the optical bandwidths
in what you and I call visible light and
as you may know NASA is doing these
tests using laser communication in other
words instead of sending radio signals
with wavelengths the size of this room
and so information packets spread out
over the size of this room you'd use
light waves where the information
packets are just a few hundred billions
of a meter long and so you can get a lot
more it's fiber-optic you get a lot more
the comparison of fiber-optic with
traditional copper wire you get a lot
more information a lot more bandwidth so
who knows maybe the aliens are sending
this optical signal
we missed the point whatever with the
come on one way to be sure you never
hear from another civilization and
realize or validate Fermi's paradox is
to not listen so this to me is an
obligation of a civilization of a
civilized society is to prevent is to
present or to allocate just a little of
our intellect and treasure to the search
for extraterrestrial life because
there's two questions that get everyone
of us where did we come from
where did we come from and that's by the
way what the rosetta mission is working
on it's going to a comet which is part
of the primary seems to be and said
certainly part of the primordial solar
system so by understanding that will
understand more about where we all came
from and the second question is are we
alone could we possibly be alone in the
universe and to answer those questions
you have to explore space that's what we
do at the Planetary Society did I
mention that planetary org then I bring
us up thank you